منذ اربعه اعوام واللبنانيون يبدلون سبل
المحافظه على اموالهم بعد ان خسروا ما
ادخروه داخل المصارف وبعد ان ملات العملات
الصعبه خزائن منازلهم قرروا استبدالها
اليوم بالعمله المعدنيه خاصه الذهب حتى ان
الطلبه ازداد لدرجه فقدت معه الليرات
والانصات من الاسواق ذهب اكيد لا انا ذهب
بدلا قيمته في المصاري عم تطلع ايمتى تنزل
قيمتها
ذهب لانه الذهب مثل ما هو
الصراحه لا
ما في مصاري
مش لاقلي للشغل
اذا معي مصاري بساعد العالم لوغني انا
فقير ما بشتري لذهب ولا شيء
معروف من الف سنين هو الاساسي بقى واليوم
العمله الورقيه انت بتعرفي وين ما كان عم
تتلخبط كلها
بتشوفي 95% الاتجاه على الاونصات والليرات
لا ينكر رئيس نقابه التجار الذهب
والمجوهرات في لبنان ان محال الذهب تاثرت
سلبا مع بدايه الازمه الاقتصاديه ولكن
الاوضاع تغيرت خاصه بعد اندلاع الحرب
الاوكرانيه حينها تخطى حجمه مبيع الاونصات
الاربعين اونصه يوميا لدى التجار 2022 او
قبل شوي وصلت الاونصه لل 1625 دولار زاد
الطلب وحتى السوق المحلي ما عاد
يلبيات يعني تصوري اللي بده يشتري كان
اونصات او ليرات يحجز قبل بيومين ثلاثه
اربعه خمسه او يدفع حقهم لبعد اسبوع
ليستلم من هيك كان في ضغط كتير كتير قوي
على الذهب
لمعلي لا صياغه ولا عليه شغل تحولت العمله
المعدنيه الى مدخرات اصحاب الرساميل
الصغيره اما كبار المستثمرين فيلجاون الى
السبائك وكيلوات الذهب بين العمله الورقيه
وليرات الذهب يفضل اللبنانيون ما يضمن عدم
خسارتهم مره اخرى
لمدخلات عادوا لجمعها من الصفر غنو يتيم
العربيه بيروت لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات